turns out Justin Bieber is a  bachelorette fan hey guys i'm lauren  zima now I love this franchise and there  are some well-known celeb devotees just  sit on the couch order some takeout  turn on the bachelor and now we can add  the Biebs to the fan club  looks like he's catching up on recent  episodes justin instagrammed this vid of  this season's infamous villain shad have  a glass of milk don't like milk don't  need any said no submission  Justin caption to that good point Chad  milk is delicious  it could be Omega no no will ever be our  member Biebs also confessed quote yeah I  watch The Bachelorette don't judge me  zero judgment here Justin The  Bachelorette airs Monday nights check ET  online for all the latest coverage milk  is a bad choice it was a great choice